You're getting subway juice on you.
- That's very New York.
- Yeah, I know.
- So we're heading down to Williamsburg
for lunch, taking the subway down there.
On the way down, we're gonna get in a quick
game of Truth or Dare, have a little fun—
- Beautiful.
- With some New Yorkers here.
- Truth or dare?
- Truth.
- Your first at-bat this year came against Max Scherzer.
- Yeah.
- Chased a slider, first pitch.
- Yep.
- What's going through
your head at that point?
- Well, I just wanted to get
the first hit out of the way.
It was kinda just like, "Oh, wow.
I'm here."
Took a big rip with that,
with that first swing.
It's like, "Hey, Max Scherzer did what Max
Scherzer does by making it not be there."
Thankfully I got first one
out of the way my last at-bat.
- [Announcer]: Looped into center
field, that's gonna fall for a base hit.
Pete Alonso with his first big league hit.
- We'll go to another truth.
What's the scouting report
on Tebow the baseball player?
- I'm not gonna give it away
because he's a former teammate.
I don't want to give away his
thing, but I'll give you a fun fact.
He does not believe in the baseball gods.
- How does that play out for him versus most
people who do believe in the baseball gods?
- Guys that have been in the game for a
while, it's like they know the baseball gods
are a thing.
Our shortstop made this
unbelievable diving catch.
I said something like, "Oh, baseball
gods," or something about it.
It's like, "They're gonna do him right."
And he's like, "What the
hell are you talking about?"
Or, "What the heaven are you talking about?"
because it's Tim talking.
Next pitch.
he whacks a double off the wall, and
I just kinda look at him and smile.
He didn't talk to me for the rest of the day.
- He's got the football gods.
- Nope.
No football gods.
- All right, Pete.
Truth or dare on this stop?
- I'll do a dare.
- I've heard you have a
pretty good New York accent.
So the dare is, I want you to approach
someone on the subway and ask for directions
to Citi Field with this great New
York accent that I've heard about.
- I gotta get
--
All
right.
Hey, excuse me, sir.
Can you do me a huge favor?
Can you give me directions to Citi Field?
Cuz I don't know if I'm in
the right direction or not.
- You see my hat?
- I don't care if you're a fan or not.
I just need directions to Citi Field.
- I don't care, bro.
This is New York, man.
Figure it out.
- Just please out of the
kindness of your heart.
- Gimme money.
- Money?!
- Yeah, bro.
Money?!
- What do you wanna do, truth or dare?
- I just did a dare, so I'll just do, I'll do a truth to mix it up a little bit.
- All right. Can you outlift everybody on the Mets?
- Probably not. I mean, Noah gets after it. I mean, Buffalo's a really large human being.
I mean, I can move some weight around for sure. But if anyone, probably Buffalo.
- Yeah?
- I'll put this in there: Noah bruises like a peach.
- We got a little bit of time, got
another chance for a truth or dare.
What you wanna do?
- I'll do a dare.
- I was hoping you'd say that.
You know, you're kind of
a new star in New York.
The dare will be complete when you give them
your autograph and when you get them to sign
this Mets hat in exchange.
- Hey, do you want my autograph?
- [Announcer]: Monstrous home
run off the bat of Pete Alonso!
- Who are you?
- Pete Alonso.
- [Announcer]: Monstrous home
run off the bat of Pete Alonso!
- First baseman for the Mets.
- Really?
- Here, pull up a picture on your phone.
- I believe you, I believe you.
- You sure?
- Yeah. Sure, I would like your autographed hat.
- No, no, no, you're supposed to sign this for me.
What if I sign your jacket right there?
Beautiful.
Can you sign this for me?
That's a sweet sig.
Let's go, Mets.
- Let's go.
- Let's go, Mets.
- So truth or dare, Pete.
- Uh, truth.
- What do you think about
the nickname Polar Bear?
- I love it.
I mean, Todd was just kinda messin' around,
and he was just like, "You just look like a
big damn polar bear."
And I'm just like, "All right."
- So we made it to Brooklyn.
We have one more dare for you—
- OK.
- Before we're done here.
We want you to give a polar bear hug to the
next person who comes through the turnstiles.
- I might get punched in the face.
- [Laughing]
- I dare you to scream it.
- [Chanting] Yankees suck!
Yankees [laughing]